joining us on the line is josh rogan he
is a columnist for the global opinion
sections of the washington post and a
political analyst
with cnn he's also the author of the
book chaos under heaven trump g
and the battle for the 21st century it's
available now wherever books are sold
josh thanks so much for joining the show
i really appreciate it great to be on
with you
so why don't we start with the battle
royale that happened in the senate the
other day between
dr anthony fauci the second greatest
doctor in america after dr joel biden
and uh and rand paul senator from
kentucky uh so senator paul
was questioning dr fauci about gain of
function
research and it seemed like the entire
exchange centered on
almost a semantic battle in which dr
fauci was arguing that
he had not greenlit nor had the nih
green led any funding to the wuhan
institute of virology in china for
quote-unquote gain of function research
but he defined gain of function research
incredibly specifically
meanwhile senator paul was saying well
if you take an animal virus and you make
it applicable to humans which is stuff
that they do in the wuhan institute of
virology
that's going to function research you
were funding it not saying that
covet 19 came from that funding but that
possibility does exist what did you make
of the exchange
you know this is the latest saga where
you know anthony fauci and his
band of uh best friends have spent over
a year and a half trying to distract and
deflect from the
possible yet still unproven theory that
the wuhan labs were somehow linked to
the pandemic to the
crisis that we're all suffering through
all over the world and you know
you're right it's a semantic debate over
whether or not what the us government
was funding in wuhan
is gain of functional research the truth
is that it was
the nih and anthony fauci who made the
definition so
then we put anthony fauci and the nih in
charge of
judging which projects met that
definition then we put anthony fauci and
the nih in charge of
excusing themselves from their own
mechanism that they built to
worry about risky research that was
going on that was funded by u.s
taxpayers so the problem really here
is not whether or not anthony fauci
thinks this is gain of function research
or rand paul things of gain of
functional research the point that paul
was trying to make
is that we have this whole system of
scientific collaboration with china
that was overseen by the nih and anthony
fauci and there was no accountability
and no transparency
and they were doing risky stuff whether
the lab league theory is
true or not and someone's got to be held
accountable for that and someone's got
to
be uh held responsible for that and then
we have to change how we manage our
scientific collaboration with china
and maybe not put in place the same
system where
the people who somehow figured that gain
of function research wasn't gain of
function research are in charge of
making all these decisions because if we
don't take a real good look at this
whole system of virus research
and scientific collaboration with china
whether or not the lively theory is true
we know there's a risk there and if we
don't even bother to talk about it
openly
then we're missing a huge pathway to the
next pandemic and
that's why anthony fauci and peter
dashak and all these guys want us to do
they want us to
forget about the lab don't look at the
lab and i say
why are you telling us not to look at
the lab and that's not your
responsibility and you're a public
servant when a u.s
senator tells asks you for information
about this
it's your responsibility to give it to
them and don't tell us that you're
infallible because
in the united states of america we don't
have infallible scientists we don't have
infallible public service everyone
deserves scrutiny especially when
you're funding a chinese lab that's
performing risky research on the
doorstep
of the pandemic and josh one of the
things here that
sort of goes by the wayside is that this
does actually have some relevance for
the hesitancy of people to get
vaccinated for example that if the idea
is that we're supposed to
institutionally trust
people like anthony fauci the nih that
are our public health
advisors are perfectly honest with us
every time they're dishonest with us it
undermines their credibility when they
say things like
you know the mrna vaccines are
completely safe now i'm an advocate of
the mrna vaccines i've been telling
people to get vaccinated if they're at
risk
literally since the beginning of the
pandemic i'm vexed my wife is back my
parents are vexed
but the the notion that the people who
ought to be in control of all public
health messaging
are the folks directed top down from the
white house honestly i think it's
driving a huge amount of the blowback i
think there are a lot of people out
there who are saying
i don't trust you with regard to how you
were treating trump i don't trust you
without with regard to the who i don't
trust you with regard to china i don't
trust you with regard to masking what
you reversed on i don't trust you with
regard to schools which you reversed on
i don't trust you with regard to masking
after vaccination which you're about to
reverse twice on because first you said
that you should mask then you said you
don't have to mask now you're about to
say you have to mask again i don't trust
you on any of this stuff and yet you're
telling me that i should shoot something
in my body
because i should trust you you know all
of this undermines the public confidence
necessary in order for people to
actually feel comfortable
vaccinating if they're not already
comfortable you know i have to agree
with you ben
and it's tragic for the reason that you
started out with is because we everybody
should get vaccinated i'm vaccinated my
wife is vaccinated my parents are
vaccinated
get the vaccine that's my number one
message second like you have to admit
that you know the mishandling of all of
these issues since the start of the
pandemic not just by anthony fauci but
by all of our officials
uh by the cdc et cetera of course that
undermines public confidence and
what they tell us now and you that would
lead one to think that both in the media
and in the scientific community and in
the public policy community we should
just
admit when we got things wrong it would
be totally different if anthony fauci
could just
come out and say hey listen you know
maybe we didn't have enough oversight of
these chinese labs that were doing risky
research
because we didn't know that they were
building the other side of the lab the
side they didn't tell us about the side
where they were working with the chinese
military where they took our good
meaning open science
collaboration and weaponized it on the
other side of the lab in a secret way
that's what the biden administration
confirmed that's what the trump
administration
found out and if anthony fauci would
just say to us okay well listen maybe
the processes we had in place to vet
dangerous virus research need to be
updated because apparently
there was some loopholes okay it seems
like there were some loopholes i think
people would take that a lot more
uh uh seriously again it sort of gets
back to what we were talking about
before in america we place our trust in
institutions not individual leaders
that's what makes us different than
china or iran or north korea we don't
have dear leaders we don't have supreme
leaders
we don't have general secretaries we
don't have crown princes we don't have
infallible scientists okay
and we always do this in the media we
build up these public servants to be
these gods and then we act shocked when
they find out
they're not perfect they're human beings
they're flawed they make mistakes they
could also have conflicts of interest
and
we have to be honest about the fact that
anthony fauci has a clear conflict of
interest when it comes to this issue
okay if the lab leak theory is proven to
be true we don't know
you don't know i don't know maybe even
anthony fauci doesn't know but if so
that implicates that entire industry of
scientific collaboration
and the entire industry of digging up
dangerous viruses and bringing them into
a bunch of chinese labs
which by the way is our current planned
response to this pandemic
so if anthony founder is telling us not
to look at the labs or his new position
right because the
the anti-lab league people retrenched
and now the position is like well it
could be either one i'm not really sure
but we'll never figure it out
and if you just think about that for one
second well they're admitting that they
have no idea what's going on in these
chinese labs that
uh we were funding one way or the other
and of course money is fungible so it
doesn't matter if you funded the virus
that
caused the pandemic that's very unlikely
what's more likely is that we
taught these scientists how to make
dangerous viruses then we built them a
lab along with the french
and then uh you know we just kept
pumping money into it
and then when we found out that the
pandemic you know
broke out 10 miles from the lab uh they
told us to go pound sand they told us
we're not
allowed back into the lab so what is
that and that just again sort of tells
us that
you know science bureaucracy officials
uh can't be in charge of our national
security they don't understand the
chinese communist party
uh they clearly don't understand uh what
the chinese system was willing to do
on the other side of the lab so i think
that means we need to sort of
take anthony fauci down off his pedestal
that doesn't mean there's like
bad there aren't bad faith attacks
against him there are but there are also
some good faith attacks to him
and in the media we should be skeptical
of our public servants not seeking to
canonize them at every opportunity and
josh this is the thing that drives me
totally up a wall is is this conflation
between scientific figures and quote
unquote the science
i've been talking all along on this show
like literally since the beginning of
the pandemic
that it's important to follow the data
it's important to analyze the data there
are certain people who are more reliable
with data than than
other people i was not anti-failure
basically until fauci started declaring
at the beginning of this year that even
after you were vaccinated you might
still have to wear a mask and then it
turned out that he was just fibbing
about that and
he really didn't and then he sort of
admitted that and the but there has been
this move
including from people like fauci to say
that if you disagree with him
then you're disagreeing with the science
i mean fouchy literally said that he
went on national television and said the
attacks on me
are quote unquote attacks on science and
it's like well no
maybe some of them are attacks on
science by people who don't want to
pay attention to the data but maybe some
of the attacks are because you appear on
the cover of
in touch magazine while declaring that
you are the voice of all science in the
united states and and flip-flopping on
pretty much every issue that you've ever
touched on this sort of stuff
yeah i mean first of all it's in it's
insane to think that you know
uh any public servant who's paid who is
funded by the u.s taxpayer who draws a
salary from the u.s treasury
uh can would say on national tv that
there uh can't be criticized i mean we
can't have a system like that
uh but moreover i think what's important
to note here is there is no scientific
consensus on any of this stuff
robert redfield the head of the cdc
during the outbreak of virologists
unlike anthony thought she's not a
virologist by the way but robert
redfield said on national television
that he believes
the the pandemic came from game of
function research at the wuhan labs
and there was silence everybody ignored
him where is that guy have you seen him
he's in the federal witness protection
program
why can't he get a hearing somebody put
that guy in front of a bible
and a bunch of senators and let's hear
his story you know why because
he actually had saw all the intelligence
he actually had better
contacts with the chinese cdc and he is
pretty sure that this came from
one of the wuhan labs that was doing
risky back coronavirus research near the
pandemic outbreak okay
so it's not just that the arrogance of
claiming that you represent science it's
the
misleading aspect of pretending that
there is some scientific consensus this
is what we're seeing in the uh lab leak
debate right now it's up for a couple of
weeks everybody in the media was like oh
wait a second maybe after a year and a
half
we shouldn't dismiss the lab league
theory out of hand and then the head of
the who said hey everybody there was a
premature push to dismiss the lab league
theory
he's talking about fouchy and friends in
their letters 20 scientists came up with
a paper that said don't look at the lab
now they came up with another paper that
says okay we checked again you still
don't have to look at the lab
and you know the binding administration
is doing this like intelligence review
of the of the all
both theories the natural origin theory
and the lab league theory and they're
trying to do it honestly
but they don't understand they're not
looking at our labs
it's not just nih this is the other
thing a lot of people get wrong but it's
really important for your audience to
understand
fauci is a piece of the puzzle we were
funding these wuhan labs through usaid
the pentagon the national science
foundation the department of homeland
security
okay the defense threat reduction agency
we were pumping tens of millions of
dollars
into chinese labs that just told us to
go screw ourselves when we asked if we
could go inside the lab to check out
whether the pandemic came from there
okay
that is a crazy system and the people
like anthony fauci and peter dashak who
are telling us
don't look at that system whatever you
do look at some markets look at some
mink farms
let's go look for pangolins and palm
civets and indonesian caves
and i say to that i want those people to
go look for palm civets and pangolins in
indonesian games for the next 10 years
i i hope they'll do that and if they
find the pandemic
pangolin i will leave the ticker tape
parade to celebrate their
scientific achievement meanwhile someone
else has got to check out these labs
okay
and we have to realize that when we hear
anthony fauci and peter dashak in his
crowd
tell us not to look at the labs they're
doing that for a reason and that's not
to say that they're
evil people that's not to say that they
broke any laws it's just to say that
they have a clear conflict of interest
that we have to factor into our analysis
and scientists are are good at science
but they're not in charge of public
policy
and they're definitely not in charge of
our discourse and we have a
responsibility as
first of all representative the people
in in congress and then the fourth
estate
that's you and me uh to educate our
audiences about
the com these conflicts of interest so
that they can make informed decisions
about how our government is performing
that they're paying for
we're speaking with josh rogan columnist
for the global opinion section of the
washington
post he's also a political analyst with
cnn his book is chaos under heaven trump
g and the battle for the 21st century
let's talk for a second about the larger
u.s china relationship
it seems like this would be an excellent
opportunity for the united states to
mobilize the west to actually start to
isolate china in some pretty serious
ways china
is a terrible actor on the world stage
not only have they
performed really the first large-scale
reduction of human freedom since the
cold war
and subjecting hong kong to complete
tyranny and now they're threatening
taiwan they're threatening the south
china sea
but also they are horrible actors when
it comes to stealing our technology
uh they're engaging in all sorts of
predations
vis-a-vis global capitalism they're
basically weaponizing corporations that
do business in china against
their home countries they're basically
saying if you don't do what we want you
to do we'll cut off our markets
to you and then all these corporations
start mirroring their priorities and yet
the west
seems oddly complacent to continue
moving along lockstep
with china we still believe it seems as
though
in sort of the pre-shi era that if we
just continue to
make capitalist overtures to the chinese
market then the leadership in china will
start to moderate
i'm unaware of any place on earth that
this has been a particularly effective
strategy
and it seems like isolating communist
regimes and totalitarian regimes have
been a lot more effective historically
speaking than trying to do business with
them and enriching them over the course
of time it seems like the entire west is
unwilling to
take the economic hit of severing many
of their economic ties with china china
knows it and they're they're reversing
the sort of power polarity here what's
your take on how the west should be
confronting china
right in that long litany of uh
grievances for the chinese communist
party all of which were correct you left
out one the genocide the genocide of
muslims on our watch
okay millions of uyghurs and other
minorities in camps
uh you know suffering torture and abuse
forced labor on a mass scale
uh mass surveillance uh and then the
other thing is interference and freeing
open societies on a range of fronts
we're talking about the seating of
western institutions
uh with billions and billions of dollars
in cash uh the
economic expansion military expansion uh
increased repression it's all going in
one direction which is a clear signal
that xi jinping
is taking china it uh backwards it's the
great leap backwards that's what we're
witnessing okay and we're struggling to
respond as you uh correctly point out
but
what the pandemic showed i think every
country in the world is that
what happens in beijing no longer stays
in beijing and that the ccp's increasing
aggression and repression are no longer
far away
problems they affect us in our lives and
in our culture and in our society in our
corporations in
our sports and in our markets and in our
tech companies and
it's everywhere and it's a shared
problem that we need to work on together
we need to de-politicize it right now
and then we need to tackle it now how
that relates to what we were talking
about is that
you would think that scientific
collaboration would be the thing
that the us and china two global
superpowers who don't agree on much
could
agree on so for anyone out there who is
uh still preaching this idea that
oh well we have to focus on engagement
and cooperation well if we can't
cooperate on
a pandemic what exactly can we cooperate
on okay
and that leads you to only one
realization which is that what's going
on in china
uh is that the party is taking control
of all of its institutions
and that's just the reality that we have
to work with and that means we have to
yes exactly what you said deal with it
deal with oppression and
aggression wherever it pops itself up
and also convince our allies and
partners to do the same thing now that's
a generational project that we're only
it's beginning that's what the book is
aimed to do it seemed to bring people to
an awakening a level of understanding
about the challenge that we're dealing
with
right but that but what that says to me
is that first of all we have to make
this a huge
priority in our foreign policy and then
we have to have a national conversation
about the threat that the chinese
communist party poses to free it up in
societies all over the world that's the
conversation we're having right now
well this is josh rogan columnist for
the global opinion section of the
washington post's book is chaos under
heaven trump g and the battle for the
21st century josh thanks so much for
your coverage and
thanks for joining the show anytime i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show
if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button so you stay up to date
with all our future content